uns durch die korona krise steuern das
ist vor allem ihre aufgabe frau merkel
dazu brauchen sie entscheidungskraft
dazu brauchen sie die wissenschaft auch
und dazu brauchen sie auch ein gefühl
für den alltag der menschen also für
unseren alltag
aber jetzt sind sie für die masten
pflegt sogar für grundschüler auf dem
schulhof und sie sind für diese ein
freund regel das heißt uns kinder sollen
sich entscheiden für nur noch einen
freund den sie treffen dürfen sie sitzen
tagsüber mit 25 leuten im klassenraum
und nachmittags nach dem gong dürfen sie
nur noch einen freund treffen
das ist ein tiefer eingriff in die
kindheit in die kindlichkeit unserer
kinder und das ist eine regel ohne herz
ohne wärme finde ich eine regel ohne
gefühl für unseren alltag